Every time the Republicans are talking about abortion,
we're losing.
Right, because we don't do it well as a party. Right?
I think the next generation of Republican isn't.
That's not a top priority for them.
I think we need to talk about things that matter,
like inflation and homelessness
and mental health access
and opioid and drug treatment recovery programs.
Those are the things that impact families
every single day.
And every time we start trying to wrap ourselves
as a party around the Axel
on where we should be on abortion,
look, it should be a states issue.
It should be out.
It is effectively
out of the hands of the federal government.
That we shouldn't be doing national abortion bans
or anything like that.
And every time we talk like that,
and every time we talk about more restrictive laws,
we're losing